[Música]
bienvenidos a ella soy de france 24 cada
año del 2 al 8 de agosto se celebra la
semana mundial de la lactancia materna
este año el lema es proteger la
lactancia las mujeres y las familias
necesitamos tiempo para parir para
recuperarnos y para nutrir a nuestros
hijos la lactancia no debe doler y no
hay nada que la reemplace
desde el siglo 20 el biberón se apoderó
del mercado para las madres la
alimentación infantil artificial comenzó
a reemplazar los conocimientos de la
lactancia transmitidos principalmente
por abuelas a las nuevas generaciones de
lactantes pero eso no acabó con el deseo
instintivo del grueso de las madres por
dar la teta pese a las informaciones
erróneas que hasta hoy se entregan en
los sistemas de salud y a los mitos que
la publicidad instaló en las familias
que el seno se seca que la leche materna
no sacia o que no tiene los nutrientes
necesarios que el bebé queda con hambre
y es necesario complementar con sueros
producidos químicamente son todas frases
popularizadas por un desconocimiento que
ahora los organismos internacionales y
los expertos intentan combatir su causa
no es menor pues la leche materna es una
de las mayores armas contra la
mortalidad infantil uno de los objetivos
del milenio
unicef ratifica que la iniciación
temprana de la lactancia es una
estrategia clave para la supervivencia
del niño
un estudio realizado en ghana publicado
en 2006 en la revista médica pediatrics
asegura que es posible evitar el 16 por
ciento de las muertes neonatales si se
da pecho desde el primer día de vida de
los lactantes y la cifra aumenta hasta
el 22% si el neonato es alimentado
durante la primera hora después del
nacimiento hasta los 6 meses de vida a
un bebé no requiere más alimento que la
leche de su madre que hidrata y
proporciona todos los nutrientes y
defensas para prosperar la leche de la
madre de manera exclusiva en ese periodo
puede evitar anualmente la muerte de 1,3
millones de niños y niñas menores de 5
años sin embargo en el mundo sólo 2 de
cada 5 niños siguen recibiendo lactancia
después de los 2 meses de vida además la
organización mundial de la salud
recomienda que después de llegar a la
alimentación complementaria la teta debe
mantenerse hasta los 2 años o más
y nos acompaña a claudia garcía líder
voluntaria de la liga de la leche en su
sede de colombia claudia bienvenida a
ellas hoy y los profesionales de la
salud no tienen conocimiento de
lactancia el mercado nos vende que
nuestros hijos necesitan sucedáneos pero
eso no es cierto por qué y por qué la
falta de conocimientos
bueno muchas gracias por la invitación
pues mira la verdad es que bueno la
historia de la humanidad lleva miles de
años siempre somos mamíferos y hemos
sido amamantados siempre estamos hasta
acá porque nos han amamantado generación
tras generación las leches de fórmula
son un invento que salió en 1860 como la
primera vez y más adelante en la primera
guerra mundial a los hombres ir a la
guerra las mujeres se quedaron en casa
perdón las abuelas se quedaron en casa
porque las madres tuvieron que ir a
trabajar entonces ellas necesitaron cómo
poder alimentar a los bebés y pues de
ahí salió como este boom de la leche de
fórmula que ya se
comercializó durante la segunda guerra
mundial ya después llegó una época de la
liberación femenina en los eeuu y fue
como que se aprovechó ese momento
para
comercializar la leche de fórmula
entonces te dejo muy de lado porque la
comercialización y la publicidad de la
leche de fórmula simplemente te decía
esto es mejor que la leche materna y
pues tú siempre quieres darle a tus
hijos lo mejor entonces se empezó a dar
mala propaganda a la leche materna
entonces de esta manera pues esto empezó
hacia la leche materna peso hacia abajo
y se empezó a comercializar y ahora
todos creemos que la leche de fórmula
pues puede solucionar muchas cosas pero
es completamente lo contrario es decir
lo óptimo es alimentar un bebé con leche
materna y alimentar a un bebé con
fórmula pues no debería ser lo mejor no
todos los bebés lo necesitan es decir si
hay bebés que lo necesitan pero no todos
deberían consumirla o la mayoría por lo
menos
bueno y cuando si son necesarios
entonces claudia los sucedáneos de la
leche materna
bueno hay situaciones en las que si se
amerita
situaciones médicas de verdad que los
bebés
pues los médicos ya se dan cuenta que el
bebé necesita como un refuerzo adicional
por su desarrollo por la situación
crítica en la que esté o porque la mamá
también está digamos que en la unidad de
cuidados intensivos no la pueden no hay
manera de extraerla aunque si hay
hospitales en otros lugares del mundo
que lo han hecho digamos que no es nada
no es un protocolo que esté muy
generalizado todo el mundo
los bancos de leche materna sufren
muchas necesidades en los hospitales sin
embargo todavía no tenemos la cantidad
de bancos de leche materna ni en
colombia ni en todo en todos los
hospitales de latinoamérica que puedan
ayudar a suplir las necesidades que
tenga un bebé recién nacido para poder
dar leche materna entonces digamos que
si hay unos casos que bajo asesoría y
acompañamiento pues del pediatra o del
neonatólogo si se hace necesario pero no
es una regla general sin embargo si
debería ayudar muchísimo a que a
promoverse que la madre se
extraiga la leche que se la den en
buenas condiciones al bebé en los casos
que se necesite sería lo ideal
además de eso la lactancia no debe doler
qué hacemos para dar teta sin
sufrimiento cuando nuestras abuelas y
madres nos enseñaron que primero tiene
que salir sangre así cualquiera abandona
una lactancia
bueno la idea es que si alguna mujer le
está doliendo el pecho algo está
sucediendo entonces lo que no puede
revisar es que ojalá antes de el día del
nacimiento del bebé las madres puedan
tener presente que lo primero que entre
a la boca del bebé sea el pecho de la
madre a veces se genera mucha confusión
de succión porque en el bebé al tener
que chupar un biberón es muy diferente a
lo que hace con la boca entonces el
tener al bebé barriga con barriga en el
momento que se lo va a poner al pecho en
el momento que le va a ofrecer el pecho
es una buena solución otra cosa que las
madres también pueden revisar es que el
bebé efectivamente no esté el peso por
debajo de la lengua porque eso hace que
el bebé chupe que perdón que el bebé más
y que el peso y que la lengua esté bien
ubicada debajo del pezón para que no
sienta dolor entonces la idea sería que
siempre piensen que no que no está
succionando la puntita del pezón sino
que está entrando el pezón más allá más
hasta el fondo cualquier pecho
funciona en buenas condiciones para que
el duelo pueda succionar y si las mamás
quieren más información está la liga de
la leche para ayudar
exactamente pueden llamar a cualquier
líder en cualquier país de latinoamérica
para buscar más recomendaciones y
consejos y buscar la solución al dolor
porque algo está sucediendo
bueno pese a que es un deber ético
claudia y de la salud promover la
lactancia también debemos promover que
debe ser una decisión y que una madre
que no la cta no es una mala madre
claro que existen mujeres que tienen la
pues como esta necesidad de querer
amamantar y necesitan ayuda y
acompañamiento lo importante es buscar
información y también están en este otro
tipo de mujeres que deciden desde antes
que van a darle fórmula a sus bebés y
eso también lo pueden hacernos no
estamos diciendo que no obviamente lo
ideal sería que tuviera todas las
condiciones para poder ser amamantado
pero cualquiera de las dos o sea todas
las personas necesitamos información
para poder recibir acompañamiento en
cómo vamos a alimentar a nuestros bebés
claro el punto de su y que la decisión
de lactar o no venga de la libertad y no
de informaciones erróneas de qué tan
cierto es que la lactancia materna
prolongada es solamente para países
subdesarrollados es por eso que la
organización mundial de la salud
recomienda dos años de teta
bueno es una decisión propia es una
relación de parejas un binomio lactante
es una mamá hay un bebé entonces casi
que nadie debería involucrarse en cuando
debería terminar y eso las
recomendaciones de la mayoría de
organizaciones es hasta los 2 años o más
y hasta cuando la mamá y el bebé lo
decida y lo que pasa es que de ahí para
allá pues es una decisión muy propia y
lo que yo creo que digamos que es una
confusión muy grande es porque ya están
caminando que ya están muy adelante
entonces empiezan mucho las críticas
sociales para las madres pero esto
deberíamos es apoyarlas porque entre más
esté comiendo un bebé muchísimos
beneficios de atv esto no es de países
subdesarrollados ya tenemos la misma
calidad
física del ser humano el estar en un
país subdesarrollado de lo necesario en
estados unidos o en europa el desarrollo
del cerebro tiene que ser óptimo el
desarrollo del organismo del sistema
nervioso central del aparato digestivo
eso es lo que ayuda a promover los
componentes de la leche materna a que el
desarrollo óptimo de todos los sistemas
del cuerpo humano pues pueda llegar a su
desarrollo
pues algo a lo que tiene que ser para
cualquier ser humano y eso lo
necesitamos todos los más desarrollados
y los subdesarrollados entonces no esto
no es un tema de países subdesarrollados
mire hay muchas abandonan la lactancia
por discriminación porque por cultura
sexual izamos la teta y esto se trata
más bien de nutre de nutrición y al
final de ahorrarnos millones y millones
en los sistemas de salud
los pechos fueron y tenemos nuestros
pechos es para alimentar a nuestros
bebés se fueron formando ya pues como en
la evolución del hombre esta connotación
sexual pero las investigaciones
antropológicas dicen que están hechos es
obviamente para poder alimentar a
nuestros bebés entonces pues bueno ya
es muy difícil dejar esta que tú dices
de la discriminación y de las críticas
porque pues estamos en nuestra sociedad
actualmente en la que estamos vistas así
y pues está también en nosotras las
mujeres en sentirnos seguras empoderadas
tranquilas y confiadas que lo que
estamos haciendo lo estamos haciendo por
nuestros bebés no lo estamos haciendo
por nadie más sino por la por el
desarrollo óptimo de nuestros hijos
bueno y al inicio de la pandemia ya para
ir finalizando vivimos un retroceso
porque separaban a las madres de sus
recién nacidos ante un virus que no
conocíamos y esto puede ser devastador
para cualquier la estancia que se debe
hacer bueno y si al principio esto
genera un caos generalizado a muchas
partes del mundo fue desafortunado pero
como tú dices estábamos ante algo que
era completamente desconocido ahorita ya
los protocolos han cambiado muchísimo
simplemente con que la madre se siga
cuidando y protegiendo con los
protocolos de bioseguridad que conocemos
todos lavado de manos amamantar al bebé
digamos y ponerse de tapabocas
todo lo que se está haciendo normalmente
puede seguir funcionando y pueden seguir
amamantando
incluso el cuerpo está generando
anticuerpos para proteger al bebé ante
la posibilidad de que también se enferme
de kobe entonces la idea es que sigan
alimentando incluso ahorita durante la
vacunación la mayoría pues las vacunas
están
están hechas también para que las madres
puedan seguir amamantando no tienen que
estar en ningún momento ni cuando estén
enfermas de kobe ni durante el proceso
de vacunación no hay ninguna limitante
para ello
pues claudia un agradecimiento para
usted por estar con nosotros en ellas
hoy y ya lo dijo en los años 50 el
doctor gregory white en illinois eeuu lo
que el bebé pide es lo que el bebé
necesita y lo que el bebé necesita este
está mucha teta sigan con nosotros en
france 24
[Música]